Twitter gate I'm sure you have seen the
headlines I'm sure you have seen a ton
of spin most people have not taken the
time to actually read through the
reporting of the story because it's very
very long and somewhat intricate I won't
bore you with all of the details I will
give you the highlights though because
this is at least as corrupt
as we all thought it was and in some
ways it seems much more so
Twitter
was conspiring
with the libs
to rig the platform which is in many
ways the new Public Square for the libs
and against the Republicans
which is a big deal because we at least
notionally have a self-governing
republic so whoever controls the Public
Square controls the political order
because the way the political order
works is that we all persuade one
another of how we want to live in the
Public Square so Twitter is not just
some tech platform it's not just some
app that we do scroll on Twitter
represents
well it represents the American
political order it represents the way
that we speak to one another and
persuade one another and Twitter
colluded with the libs to rig it and
exclude the conservatives Matt taibi is
a liberal journalist he's a guy who's
got bylines and all sorts of lib Outlets
but he's become disillusioned with some
of the liberal journalists in recent
years and so he's the guy that Elon
seems to have picked to give this story
to and he says Hey here are the docs run
with it Matt Tybee do your thing so we
see from the very beginning that the
Biden team by 2020 was regularly
requesting that Twitter takedown tweets
that they didn't like
so they would just send emails in and
say hey there's more to review from the
Biden team we don't like this tweet we
don't like that tweet we don't like this
tweet we don't like that tweet and it
just random accounts sometimes
politically minded accounts sometimes
the accounts of of regular
actors Hollywood celebrities James Woods
in particular was targeted so the the
actor at James Woods you know one of the
greatest tweeters of all time he had his
account targeted
by the DNC they said an additional
report from the DNC take down the stupid
James Woods tweet James Woods is now
threatening to sue over this uh but but
you see why would they go after James
Woods or other people like that because
they had huge accounts and the those
accounts were going after the Biden team
so they say take it down okay now how
how were the takedowns being done
the Republicans would sometimes request
to take things down as well the problem
is there was no neutral system there was
no formal system at all for this to take
place it was just kind of based on who
you know so if you knew somebody at
Twitter you could email them and say hey
Uncle Joe doesn't really like that tweet
let's get rid of it okay hey I don't
like what James Woods said take that
down and they would do it meanwhile the
Republicans say hey guys come on you're
we're getting death threats over here
people take down this tweet but it would
be like howling into the wind because
nobody at Twitter likes the Republicans
and you can see this based on the
political donations of the people at
Twitter if you look at open Secrets the
donations are just all to Democrats in
the 2022 cycle the donations from
Twitter to Democrats came to 166
thousand dollars the donations from
Twitter to Republicans 451.
not 451 451 dollars that means that the
percentage to Dems was 99.73 percent
2020 cycle 98.47 percent of donations to
Democrats the 2018 cycle 96.38 of
donations to Democrats so not only were
the were the Twitter employees
statistically all giving to Democrats
but or all of the donations we're going
to Democrats but it was actually getting
worse over time it was skewing even more
toward the Democrats over time so no
surprise that the Republicans couldn't
couldn't get the post that they wanted
taking down Democrats almost always did
then you get to the hunter Biden laptop
story so this was the story broken by
the New York Post that they found this
laptop from Hunter Biden that had a ton
of evidence of crimes
not just drug crimes not just sex crimes
being committed by Hunter Biden but
potential political and financial crimes
being committed by Hunter Biden on
behalf of the Biden family trading on
Joe Biden's name while Joe Biden was the
point man to Ukraine for instance
scoring crooked deals in Ukraine trading
on the Biden name while Biden was
serving at the highest levels of the
government to get money out of China
getting meetings arranged between
between these extremely corrupt actors
all around the world and Joe Biden
Hunters the Nexus of that what happens
Twitter says you can't share this story
not only does Twitter say you can't post
the story publicly and then Facebook and
Google followed suit but they say you
couldn't even privately message The
Story So this this step
which says you can't even privately
message something was previously a
mechanism reserved only for child
pornography and it's true actually that
on Hunter Biden's laptop there was it
would appear to be some evidence of
pornography where the girls didn't
totally look 18. uh but that's that's
not the point here we're not talking
about the actual contents of Hunter
Biden's laptop we're talking about a
story in the New York Post so obviously
there's no child pornography in the
story they just went as far as they
possibly could they said this material
is unsafe so now we're going to have a
new category it's a category of content
that is so dangerous that involves child
pornography or something that threatens
the Biden campaign that's it that's that
is now the most extreme category on
Twitter the executives almost
immediately start start raising
questions about this the public policy
executive Carolyn Strom sends an email
out to to several people on the team
saying uh hey guys
are you sure about this are you sure are
we sure that this is this is really
something that that should be banned
from the public platform and such that
you can't privately message it and what
Tybee found out is there was a big
tension between the communications and
policy teams which had basically no
control over moderation and the safety
and Trust teams and those were the ones
who were censoring everybody and
ultimately who would even censor the
duly elected sitting president of the
United States that the next claim that
was made by these guys is that it was a
hacked material so because okay forget
about yeah it's obviously not child
pornography but it's very possibly
hacked materials and so we can't allow
that to be uh spread all around the the
internet again this doesn't hold up at
all
you're seeing uh you're seeing messages
from these top execs saying are you sure
does this is this really going to to
hold up it doesn't really make a lot of
sense to us then the crazy part is Jack
Dorsey was the CEO of Twitter apparently
had no idea what was going on he was not
the guy who made the call to censor the
hunter Biden story he he was I think
away from the office at this point so
that call was made by the former head of
legal policy and Trust Vijaya Gaddy who
Elon Musk nuked from Orbit on his first
day in office everybody knew that this
was messed up this is I think the
biggest Revelation from the Twitter
internal emails is we've just been
gaslit this whole time and Twitter and
big Tech they say no of course this is
totally fine this isn't keeping with our
policy there's nothing wrong here deny
till you die deny until you die you look
at those internal emails there there is
a ton of controversy hearing people are
saying gosh this is really bad we have
screwed up it's not going to hold up but
we can't back away now we've got to
stand firm you see the former trust and
safety chief of Twitter yoel Roth who is
getting into these exchanges with Vijaya
Gaddy and all these people and then you
got a Communications official Trenton
Kennedy at Twitter who says I'm
struggling to understand the policy
basis for marking this is unsafe and
then the the other team basically says
well just shut up and deal with it
everybody knew it there was even a
Democrat there was only one Democrat but
there was a Democrat member of Congress
who knew that this was a big deal that
was Ro Kana who writes to Vijaya Gaddy
the this lady who's who's taking all the
steps to ban people and uh ultimately
would ban Donald Trump and says hope
you're well Vijaya this seems a
violation of the First Amendment
principles if there is a hack of
classified information or other
information that could expose a serious
War crime and the New York Times to
publish it I think the New York Times
should have that right a journalist
should not be held accountable for the
illegal actions of the source unless
they actively aided the hack so you've
got this what this lone Democrat out
there saying guys what about the First
Amendment even if this were hacked
material which it's not by the way still
you can't just ban it from from being
circulated by the way you allow the
publication of all sorts of Republican
hacked material material that that was
hacked that does not bode well for
Republicans on your platform it just
this doesn't hold up and yet even the
Democrat admitting it
so then what happens
then what happens what happens is
the journalists
take stock of their failures right the
journalists this took two years this
shouldn't have taken two years the
journalists they come together right and
they say gosh we did not investigate
this huge abuse of power we gosh we did
not we did not speak truth to power as
we are supposed to do and and they they
looked inside themselves and they were
very introspective and just kidding they
didn't say that at all they actually
just kept Shilling on behalf of the
Democrats and they went after Matt tyvee
you've got all these liberal journalists
turning on their liberal journalist
friend for doing the job of a journalist
or at least the ideal job of a
journalist in reality journalists are
pretty much just propagandists for a
particular point of view they're not
neutral they're not merely speaking
truth to power that has never been the
case ever in the whole history of
Journalism
but with the exception of maybe some
independent people who have their own
acts to grind usually as well but you
see the the complete mask fall down by
the liberal journals in reaction to Matt
Tybee who say hey wait a second
you're not just supposed to expose the
real power structures
Ali he is a liberal journalist very
prominent on Twitter he's been at all
sorts of outlets he says Matt Tybee What
a Sad disgraceful downfall I swear kids
he did good work back in the day
should be a cautionary tale for everyone
selling your soul for the richest white
nationalist on Earth
well he'll eat well for the rest of his
life I guess but is it worth it
and I I read that and I actually didn't
get it at first I said the richest White
National who is the richest white
nationalist I realize he's referring to
Elon Musk
is he
is Elon Musk a white nationalist
I guess he's white although he is an
African-American so that complicates
things
and I guess he's white is Elon Musk even
a nationalist
I don't know that he's a nationalist
I see I see no evidence that he's a
nationalist and it made me realize the
term white nationalism that's just the
new meaningless phrase that the libs
throw around it's just the new racism
they the libs used to call everyone that
they didn't like racist and if that the
word racist ever had any meaning it
certainly doesn't anymore no one cares
at all when a liberal calls you a racist
you know you've won the argument it's
just it has no effect in the Public
Square it used to be the worst thing you
could possibly be called now I think
it's really losing steam because it's so
silly so so they have to up the the ante
and so that the new one is white
nationalist he's a what but
I I don't see even if I'm being as
charitable as I possibly can to the
left-wing point of view
I don't see how you could possibly
describe I don't I I don't I can't even
make fun of it I don't even know what
this guy would be talking about to call
Elon Musk a white nationalist so that's
just completely meaningless
and then then what's the second Church
what's this rich person you're just
selling out Matt Tybee for the rich
person this was a comment that was also
underlined by NBC's Ben Collins who says
imagine Throwing It All Away to do PR
work for the richest person in the world
humiliating s-h-i-t
who who do these people work for
who does Ben Collins work for that Ben
Collins does he work for the Little
Sisters of the Poor that's who he does
what is he no he gets his check from NBC
Universal a very very rich powerful
company
and he gets his check for the all these
guys watch Ali all the rest of them they
get their checks they get their funding
they at least at the very least they
serve the interests of
people who collectively are much much
richer than Elon Musk Elon Musk is very
rich he's one guy
the people who run NBC just just GE
right or just any of these corporations
that own the media companies
and think about the water that these
even the so-called independent
journalists carry for the wealthiest
people on Earth for people like George
Soros the largest donor to Democrat
causes in the country
it's it's just preposterous
PR doing PR work for the richest person
in the world
all journalism
has a little touch of PR to it because
all journalism has spin because all
journalism has a perspective because the
only people who go into journalism are
people who have perspectives about
things and frankly everybody has a kind
of perspective about things because
we're rational creatures and we have
moral judgment so obviously that's the
case and when we talk about journalism
journalism is very expensive it's funded
by people it's funded by people for a
reason to advance a certain view of the
world
daily wire we put I mean we're we're
self-funded in the sense that we've run
our business from basic almost from day
one you know from about a year and a
half in on cash and we've done it
because of you well why do we why do we
do it because of you because we all
share a sort of view of the world and we
share some basic principles like a
country should have borders kids should
not have their genitals chopped off
babies shouldn't be killed in the womb
many other points of view that we all
share together and then you are willing
to spend your money to help us get the
message out there and and when we're
talking about the corporate media
you've got corporations spending a ton
of money on media because they know that
it's important to have a Bullhorn in
public so they're all to some degree
PR people they're all to some degree
propagandists the question is on behalf
of whom and on behalf of what and when I
see these guys NBC and wajahat Ali and
all the rest of them just whining and
pulling their hair out over the
publication of this story it should ask
you it should it should expose I think
quite clearly who's really serving the
powerful entrenched interests you have
the entire corporate media and the
entire liberal establishment on one side
trying to suppress this story
and then you've got
one journalist and one rich guy on the
other side exposing it
a rich guy who is so incensed by this
kind of behavior that he spent 44
billion dollars to expose it so money
well spent especially
especially since it's not it's not my
money you know the rest of the show
continues now all right and this is a
music Monday baby
I told the guys I said no more rap okay
we've done enough rap
let's hold off on the wrap for a little
bit or I've had I've had enough
so they're they're going to take me back
to the 90s they're going to take me back
to the 90s and early 2000s by playing a
little alternative rock okay so I'm
going to bleach my tips in between now
and the members block I'm going to get
out some nice Quicksilver and Billabong
clothing throw out throw out a
skateboard and meet you guys over at the
member block if you're not a member
click the link in the description and
join us
foreign
[Music]
[Music]